[Music]
I don't think the history of the 2016
election will be correctly written until
it is clearly stated no Facebook no
Trump
anybody who expected a wonderful happy
global community to form on the Internet
in which everybody would share cat
videos has been gravely disappointed in
fact what's happened has been that an
already quite polarized political scene
has become even more polarized why well
remember rule number one of networks
birds of a feather flock together
Homa Philly operates so people have
naturally gravitated into into two rival
clusters if you want to put it this way
a liberal cluster and a conservative
cluster but what's fascinating is the
way that peculiarities of today's
network platforms exacerbate this
problem for example we now know that a
tweet is 20% more likely to be retweeted
for every moral or emotional word that
it uses if you want to get retweeted you
therefore are incentivized to use strong
language we can see that the the
legislators in in the House of
Representatives and Senate who have the
most Facebook followers are the most
ideologically extreme according to their
voting patterns so I think that that
Facebook and Twitter have been
configured to incentivize the expression
and sharing of extreme opinions
it isn't just fake news that we have to
worry about that we do have to worry
about that it's also extreme views both
are in fact incentivized by the
structure of the network platforms as
they existed and I think looking back on
2016 the correct analysis of that
election is not that the Russian Network
interfered and that's why Trump won I
don't think the Russian contribution was
nearly big enough for that statement to
be valid what is true is that without
the existence of Facebook and Twitter it
would have been very hard for
an outlier outside a candidate like
Donald Trump to win but those network
platforms created opportunities for a
populist that really had not existed
before and his campaign knew how to use
them and continues to know how to use
them
remember the algorithms are designed to
give you more of what you engaged with
before you may not even notice it but as
you like things as you share them you're
signalling to the network platform your
preferences and it's set up to give you
more of that because the more engaged
you are the more advertising they can
sell that's how they make their money so
I think it's time to kind of dial back
our addiction not a need for political
reasons but also because it's addictive
and addictions are bad for you the more
time you spend and we all spend crazy
amounts of time and our smartphones
using these platforms the less time you
have to read Tolstoy or my book and I
think books are actually much the best
way for human beings to get high-level
information I think it's better for your
peace of mind and it will be better for
our body politic if we all spend much
less time on our smartphones using that
Facebook and Twitter and much more time
reading books
[Music]